hard work is your ticket in it doesn't
guarantee your success there are tons of
people who work hard and are living at
the poverty level but there is nobody
who wins and doesn't work hard working
hard is your ticket in one of the
biggest reasons why I've won on YouTube
is because I've been making three videos
a day for the past five plus years three
videos a day for five plus years there
have been one or two days where maybe I
missed one video not three videos not an
entire day off maybe one video once or
twice in five years that's it it's just
been a testament to consistency every
single day videos have to go live on the
channel and I film through everything I
film through having broken my neck I've
filmed through having a concussion I
filmed through being sick I filmed
through completely losing my voice and
then having to pull up pieces of paper
with the notes written on and I filmed
through everything I think there's a lot
of people who I look up to who I think
are way better than me people who have
way more Talent than me who are way more
natural than I am at making videos and
expressing themselves and I've passed
them because I just work harder because
I just kept going because I kept making
the content one of the biggest reasons
why you are not more successful is
you're just not consistently working
hard enough at it this game of
Entrepreneurship whether you're trying
to be a YouTuber or something totally
different it's are you getting up every
single day and doing the thing that you
have to do because you're gonna get
punched in the face there's gonna be so
many setbacks rule number two raise your
environment our environment is keep
where you are your environment has been
perfectly designed to keep you exactly
where you are right now the people you
listen to the media that you consume the
habits that you do daily all of them all
of them are designed to keep you exactly
where you are so if you want to raise
your game if you want to raise your life
you need to raise your environment I've
changed a lot over the course of having
this YouTube channel the people who've
known me the best and the longest
especially in the past two to three
years I've said Evan you've changed a
lot for the better you've evolved you're
more confident you have more more Poise
you're a better speaker you you're
pushing the boundaries more you've
changed what happened how do I get that
for myself right people wanted it
whenever you are off growing and
learning and evolving other people they
want it they want a taste of it they
want to do it too because we are not
designed to just photocopy Our Lives
over and over and over again so how did
I get it I paid more attention to to my
environment I paid more attention to my
daily routines I paid more attention to
the people that I hang around with it's
important so looking at my physical
environment right look at the look at
this office look at the people behind me
this all means something to me looking
at the new design that I've had here
below putting things like my neck braces
it's down below you can't really see it
but this inspires me I walk into this
every day
my YouTube videos the channel I create
for myself
the people that I profile I'm learning
from I feel like I have garyvee in my
head I have Oprah Winfrey in my ear I've
got Elon Musk tell me what to do pushing
me to try to get better I hear these
people talking about you have to be
courageous you have to be bold you have
to believe in yourself more and when I
feel myself being nervous about
something boom boom boom boom boom it's
a push that I have to do it
and so I've designed my life I've
designed my environment to help push me
to get to the next step rule number
three take action most people don't feel
enough most people are so afraid of a
huge fail that they don't even try
you're afraid of taking a big bet you're
afraid of going into deep debt and that
fear prevents you from having the thing
that matters the most right now in your
business momentum you don't need to fail
big but you do need to start otherwise
you will never build the big business
that you're capable of building so I'm a
big fan of going from idea to action
idea to action idea to action idea to
action get an idea what do you do you
take action teach yourself train
yourself as soon as you get that idea
don't judge it don't think about it
don't plan and Ponder and strategize
because your list of ideas is a mile
long and it's not going to get any
shorter you're a genius you come with
great ideas you're going to keep coming
with ideas for the rest of your life
that list of ideas is not going to
shrink
[Music]
so how do you start moving you take
action I call it the two percent
difference instead of planning to get to
100 for your idea what's the two percent
difference that you can just do
something about right now I think your
ideas came to you for a reason I think
it's inspired why are you thinking about
this thing don't judge the reason just
go off and do something one small
conversation one small action start
building momentum that's the thing
that's missing right now is momentum you
need more momentum you're a genius you
have great ideas you should be changing
the world what's missing is momentum and
I want you to find it rule number four
love what you do this is why it's so
important that you love what you do
success is painful it's a lot of work a
lot of stress a lot of failure a lot of
rejection but the thing that gets you
through it is you love what you do you
love the process you love the work you
love the growth if you don't love the
work you do you will give up because it
will just become too painful to keep
going so at the Whole Foods this morning
when I I went to go get my Bulletproof
Coffee I ran into a friend of mine an
entrepreneur friend of mine who I told
about my tour in December before I left
and she was super excited and I had it
connected with her since I got back I
went on this three month 90 day 23 City
Tour across the us and it was amazing
happened since to meet her at the Whole
Foods this morning and she said how's
the toy what was the best part of it
and I said breaking my neck
two-thirds of the way through I broke my
neck I broke my neck in two spots I
compressed my spine I had a concussion
had to get Staples in my head all of it
she said
breaking your neck that's the best part
of your tour well that's a really
positive outlook
it's not just a positive outlook
it's the best like it actually was the
best part
because it really got the test like why
this sounds crazy but this is it this is
this is the process this is the mindset
shift I want you guys to make that you
do difficult things you love difficult
things you don't want it to be easy easy
means you're inside your comfort zone
easy means you're not pushing up against
any barriers you don't want to be easy
stop getting these easy small tiny wings
that you can snack on you do difficult
things you love taking on Amazing huge
things that's who you are that's what
you do and this was a chance for me to
grow and help cement that for myself
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five don't make
dizziness your habit most people are
crazy busy but don't get anything done
if you feel like you're crazy busy like
you barely have any enough time for
yourself that you get to the end of the
week and you know you've been you've
been hauling ass all week long you've
been you've been busting your face in
you've been working and working and
working super busy but then you look
back and you say what did I actually do
this week if that's you then this
message is for you you're busy but
you're not focused and shifting your
life begins with shifting your
priorities so I used to pride myself on
responding to email ASAP quickly like
you sent me an email 30 seconds to 60
seconds later you would get my response
I prided myself on like that's good
service that's what you should do as an
entrepreneur right like people
communicating with you you want to send
it back to them quickly I hated having
the weight and wait and wait on people
so I didn't want to be that for others
so I had all my notifications turned on
and as soon as an email came in ding
came in boom response well what made it
worse was people would then get my
response they tended to be on the
computer at the same time and then
they'd write back right away and say wow
you're really quick like thank you so
much and that fed that fed the identity
that fed the the ego and I am very fast
exactly right there's proof that this
thing works
the problem was I wasn't getting
anything important done
I was working on something and then the
notification came in and I stopped what
I was working on to go answer this email
feel great about myself that little hit
and then come back to my project like
what was I working on and it takes time
to start getting back into the flow of
working on that thing and then another
email comes in and so I ended up being
busy I was working all day long all day
long right like
lunch at the desk breakfast at the desk
dinner at the desk all day long right
wash them back to the desk there was no
breaks all day long straight through but
if I get to the end of the day out of
the week like what did I do this week
I don't know
but I answered a lot of emails
because they didn't have Focus I didn't
have priorities and when I realized that
after that happened enough times I
realized wow this isn't I'm never gonna
get close to my goals like just doing
this all I'm doing is reacting to other
people's goals when somebody shoots me
an email that's what they want they're
demanding my time
and I'm giving it to them freely because
I have no defense around my time because
I I have no respecter on time I'm just
letting it bleed out there's no time for
me to work on what I want and so I'm not
going to make any progress on the things
that I want if you want to make progress
on the things that you want you have to
carve out time for the things that you
want that's how it works and you got to
put Gates and blockades and barriers
around and say this is my focus time and
nobody's allowed in
worst case emergencies family awesome
but there aren't that many actual
emergencies
you have to be willing to let the small
balls drop
to go for the big goals in your life you
have to pick you can't do both really
well you have to pick what do you want
to be great at do you want to be great
at getting every little small thing done
and then never do the big thing or do
you want to be great at getting the big
things done and risk losing some of the
small things because by chasing down the
big things you're going to lose some
small things it's just going to happen
rule number six have a mission this is
why I hate five to ten year goals you
are not going to be the same person five
years from today as you are right now
let alone 10 years from today you won't
be the same person think of the person
who you were five years ago go back five
years from today five years subtract
five years from today's date go back to
that person could that person actually
predict what a happy successful joyous
impactful life is for who you are right
now could that person five years ago
actually predict what you today are
capable of heck no
heck no not if you've been growing none
of you've been learning not if you've
been experiencing life you're capable of
so much more today than you ever thought
was possible five years ago and so what
makes you think that the person who you
are right now can accurately predict
what you're going to love doing what
you're going to be great at your goals
your plans for the next five to ten
years it's not possible you're thinking
small here's the thing I think you could
have a five-year plan or a 10-year plan
and hit it it's just small compared to
what you are actually capable of doing
because you put the blinders on you stay
down this one course but the best course
for me is actually going to swing out
here
but you are so stubborn and so focused
Focus can be a great thing but it can
also lead you to play small for Life
instead of having five or ten year goals
I want you to replace them with a
mission rule number seven Focus the
problem is not that you're not a genius
the problem is not that you don't have
great ideas the problem is that you are
not focused you haven't said that this
is the thing this is what I have to
accomplish today this is the mission
that I am on and nothing is going to
stop me if you don't learn the focus on
what's important to you you'll never do
important things and live your life
reacting to what's important to other
people instead so I recently started a
new business with one of my thought
Leadership Academy students Jeremy he
came to my event last year I was
thinking about him on my tour this year
and said I want to start a business with
Jeremy around YouTube Consulting I get
asked a lot hey Evan can you check out
my channel hey Evan can I work with you
Haven can I hire you for XYZ looking at
my channel giving me ideas mentoring
guiding me and it's just not the
business that I want to be in but it is
a business and so I thought Jeremy
Jeremy's going to come on board he's
going to do it now when I recruited him
and called him he was not a YouTube
expert and I gave him the homework and
said listen if you want to do this
business together it's got to be
important to you I'm halfway through my
trip on my tour I'm coming back in a
month and a half here's what I need you
to know by the end of the month and a
half and I gave him resources I gave him
videos I gave him insights and analytics
and said you need to know all of this
know all of this and then when I come
back if you're ready we'll start the
business
he did he focused he made it his
priority he knew nothing about this and
all of a sudden he became an expert by
every day all day long grinding to learn
by researching everybody who is an
expert at this understanding their
methodologies their best practices
looking through all my videos my
thumbnails my strategies all the things
that I've talked about in the past
digesting it kind of like the Matrix
when Neo is in The Matrix and and he now
he can learn Kung Fu and now he learns
how to fly a helicopter all of that
stuff that's basically what he did and
when it came back in a month and a half
I put him to the test and said hey let's
do two free calls we'll take two people
from my community and say hey free free
call let's go and he blew me away with
how much he knew because he focused on
it he was a guy he went from knowing
almost zero to now being an expert to be
able to really help give value to people
and now when we're looking at
because he already knows what I'm gonna
say he already knows he's already done
the work he's done the research because
he spent that time on focused effort and
this is where I think a lot of people
feel like they're never going to win
because you may not have had the
expertise you don't have the education
it doesn't take long to become an expert
it's just focused work that you're
passionate about
focused work you could quickly become in
a matter of months an expert at
something if you just focus in on it and
dedicate your life to that thing
that you love you can easily pass people
who are experts at something who don't
love their thing
but because you're willing to take it on
you're willing to absorb think about
when you went to school how much of the
information you had in your head but you
had to read over the page four times
so if you're at the same page four or
five six times because you got lost you
got distracted that's not focused work
because you don't love that thing but
when you love something how much faster
do you retain it how much more enjoyable
is the learning process how much better
are you really quickly because you love
doing that thing
and so Jeremy got really good really
quickly because he loved it because he
attacked it because he focused on
because he made it a priority because he
didn't say well I'll spend half an hour
a week trying this new thing no that's
not how you win
now where do we go from here we'll see
does Jeremy want to be a one-man band
forever does he just want to be a
high-paid consultant does he want to
then bring on a team does he want to
expand do you want to have products
we'll see we'll see how that business
evolves and flows
but he got here in a really short amount
of time because of that focused effort
and energy and that's what I want for
you rule number eight
let your Genius out you have two choices
in life choice number one chase your
dreams and risk upsetting some people
who don't get it or Choice number two
play small for life and never do what
you're capable of because you're afraid
of what some people will say about you
most people play small and live a life
of regret I want to put pressure on you
today to step into your fear and step
into your potential so yesterday I shot
a 10-part series with Neil pasricha he
is an author who sold over a million
books and I did a 10 part series I said
Neil I have a series on how to make a
million dollars in different Industries
I want to do a 10 part series with you
on how to sell a million books you've
done it most people have never come even
close I want to pick your brain dissect
it understand what makes people
successful and how to sell a million
books and he said yesterday on camera
that his default reaction was who am I
to do this I mean I just got lucky
yeah I don't know how I did it and and
he was afraid to come on and actually
share some of his tips because most
people don't ask him this question so
I've never been asked this question
before I don't know how to respond I'm
afraid of coming on camera on the
YouTube channel with you a friend of
mine and and looking dumb and having
nothing to say
and because that was part of the reason
he had to go off and do it and so he
came up with a list of 10 things he came
up with his idea he said no I'm I work
hard Neil's one of the hardest working
authors of all time Neil is constantly
working constantly grinding constantly
finding new opportunities to write books
and promote his books he got there not
out of just luck
he got there because he worked really
hard at it and I pulled out those
lessons from him and that's the mindset
that I want people to take that's what I
want you to take
that you're not in your situation
because you're lucky you're good
you could be better you could still grow
more but your Genius you're talented
you're amazing and you need to let that
shine you need to let that out
and some people may watch you they may
watch your videos they may read your
books they may see what you produce and
say this person is so full of themselves
this person doesn't get it like you're
not going to appeal to everybody even me
even my message I'm not a controversial
guy right my message is believe how do
you hate them believe people do
right I'm not I'm not coming out with my
channel and saying this person sucks and
talking politics and all these things
that you know are going to trigger
people right that's not who I am I want
to spread belief and yet even though I
think we've got one of the best
communities uh online in the YouTube
Community people are often toxic on
different channels but shout out believe
Nation fist bump love you guys it's it's
positivity and yet we still have people
who are negative they don't get it
they want to spread negativity
in my community and so what do I do
should the answer be well I'm not going
to post content because I'm worried
about what this person's gonna say
should I not post content because I'm
not I'm not happy with the end result I
mean it was 350 videos I made public
before I was wasn't completely
embarrassed by my content embarrassed
like I couldn't watch it back I was so
embarrassed like oh it's so bad it's so
bad it's so bad post
next move on to the next one and with
practice and repetition you get better
I've done 6 000 something videos so it
took me a long time to get there you
might be able to get there a lot faster
but it's very rare that you start off
and the first thing you do pops and even
if it does don't expect everybody to
love it you're gonna get people who will
not like what you do rule number nine
just try your hardest you need to tie
yourself respect to your efforts not
your results where you get yourself love
from yourself respect your
self-confidence should not come from
winning it comes from trying because if
you tie your self-respect to winning
you'll only do things that you know
you're gonna win at and therefore you
play small for life so I'm training the
guy on my team who I've promoted and I'm
putting them in a position that is Way
Beyond his skill set Way Beyond what he
thought he'd be doing and it's a big
push outside his comfort zone he was a
guy who was doing a bunch of admin tasks
for me and now he's in charge of all of
my YouTube analytics I want him to be my
date to God I want him to go through the
thousands of videos I have on my channel
and make recommendations to say this
intro is too long this intro is too
short this thumbnail sucks you know when
you talk Evan things blow up or things
suck when you wear black people love it
anything go through all the data go
through all the analytics and tell me
where we need to make improvements so I
was on a call with him yesterday
[Music]
a serious talk with them because he's
looking for data that supports his
hypothesis because he suggested on my
channel my main channel that we go back
to my original intros where I say
one sentence here one sentence here and
one sentence here and then he's Robert S
Smith and here's my take on his top 10
rules of success right that's what we
did way back like in the very first
original series of the top tens and
we've we've evolved so he suggested take
out the song Take out the intro take out
a whole bunch of stuff I'm used to those
three things and let's see if it works
so that's what I did like great good
idea the data supported it backed it up
let's go and try we haven't tried it we
won't know so we tried it the first
video came up was the Robert F smith top
10 rules of success on that new template
and I'm looking at the data in it and it
sucked you know my goal is to get 70
artist retention at one minute that's
when that's my goal across my channels
70 on its retention at one minute that
means 30 of people Max have left at the
one minute Mark that's an insanely High
goal to reach almost nobody hits that
especially consistently you might think
oh 70 it's easy it's it's insanely
difficult in the YouTube world so I
looked at the numbers for this one and
it was 52 or something something brutal
we haven't we don't really operate in
the 52 range so this one came in it was
brutal 52 like having a heart attack oh
suck people hate this
and then I asked him hey how are we
doing on the new videos and he sent me
this report that says hey well on our
relative data is up you know a relative
of data saying compared to all videos on
YouTube this video is doing well in the
first minute
yeah but that's that's not actually the
real story because all of our videos
relative to regular YouTube if they're
looking at any video this video and even
my first video all of them every video I
make relative to a normal average
YouTube video were higher relative
that's not what I'm looking for we're
going after 70 on his retention at one
minute you know this this is where we're
focused
[Music]
it was he just didn't want to feel like
a failure
he didn't want to feel like he
recommended something to me and it
didn't work out
that he's trying to justify it by saying
well look this stat shows that it works
but it's not what we're after this
experiment so far has been an epic
failure and that's okay what I need you
to do is expect to suck expect the ideas
not to work nope know that coming in
know that coming in we're already
operating a really high level
right if every experiment that we try
works that means that we just sucked at
the beginning right we sucked
you're learning you're picking this up
most of my new experiments don't work
I'm trying hundreds of new things all
the time and most of them won't work I
expect to suck but it's okay because I
tie myself forth to the effort am I
putting my Max effort out your
experiment I'm talking to the guy your
experiment was a great test I backed it
the data suggested we do it but it's not
working
and we'll give it a month to see and if
it still doesn't work we're going to
move on to do something else in rule
number 10 the last rule before a special
bonus clip is believe 95 of the world
wakes up and drives to a job that they
hate I believe that you have Michael
Jordan level Talent at something that
you are a genius you are the best the
best at something most people either one
have no idea what that thing is or two
they have found it but they don't have
the courage or belief to go chase it
down either way the path is through you
need to find the thing that you are a
genius at that you have Michael Jordan
level Talent at and live it every single
day if you want to live your life
instead of regret your life now I have a
very special bonus rule around how to
enjoy the process that I think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point Landing questions
time to go from watching the video to
taking action here we go question number
one whether you just need to be trying
harder question number two what can you
do to raise your environment this week
and number three what is one action you
need to take today to move your mission
forward live in a joyful life comes from
enjoying the process of what you are
doing when you wake up every morning do
you look forward to the work that you're
about to do today or do you hate it do
you dread it and want to stay in bed if
you are waking up and going to do work
that is torture to you that you don't
enjoy that you dread on a daily basis
you will never be joyful or successful
and I want to change that so is on a
call yesterday with a buddy of mine who
had built a Million Dollar Plus business
and he said Evan I don't know what to do
I'm I'm unhappy I'm depressed I don't
like my business I've built this
business that I hate going to and I've
always hated most of what I've done I've
had success I've built a Million Dollar
Plus business but I've always hated the
work and I thought you have to hate the
work to get the results that you want
but I keep hearing you and all these
other successful people saying you gotta
love the process you gotta love the work
so what do I do man I don't know what to
do do I do I shut the whole thing down
do I keep building what do I do I'm
[Music]
like there's something that you love
inside your business what do you love
doing and it started off was well I like
giving people strategy I like doing the
strategy part of my business but I don't
like the rest of it okay great so Step
One is you're gonna start doing all the
strategy work in your business amazing
what else like while I also like selling
okay awesome you're gonna be the chief
salesperson you're going to be off
selling and meeting people and having
conversations it's like I don't like
delivering I don't like the operations
awesome that's why you've hired your CEO
to run your company
and then he said I also like having
conversations and mentoring people not
everybody on my team likes to be
mentored but I love mentoring people I
love guiding them so he's got three
things that he loves doing he looks
forward to that he wishes he could do
all day and luckily those are high value
skills for his business right he wants
to be able to set the strategy and help
his clients with strategy he wants to be
able to sell and he wants to be able to
mentor and guide the people on his team
he just doesn't want to deliver
so you either become a consultant where
this is all you do or you hire somebody
who he's already bought on who's your
CEO and give him more lateral give him
more abilities give him more power give
him more permission and at the same time
if he loves mentoring and training
people he loves people who will listen
to him and be open to his guidance and
wisdom then he needs to have a team who
respects him who wants that and not
everybody will you could have the
greatest person who can write copy or
the greatest programmer or the greatest
whatever for your business but if you
love mentoring and they don't want to be
mentored that's not a good fit
so you need to do an assessment on your
team and see who loves being mentored by
you and keep those people because
if you go into work every day and you
see the people who you love being with
who you love mentoring who you feel like
you're a team with you'll love going to
work but if you go to work every day and
you see these people who don't want to
listen to you who don't want to be
trained you don't want to be mentored
just want to sit down and do their work
it's not going to be a joyful experience
for you
and that lack of Joy will mean you won't
have success in your company as well and
so he's built up this machine that he
hates because he always thought you need
to hate the work like work is work it
sucks but you get the results like no
dude it's the exact opposite you've had
success you built a Million Dollar Plus
business because you're talented but it
should have been a 10 million dollar
plus business by now
and if you want more Evan check out his
top 50 rules video the link is right
there next to me continue to believe and
we'll see you there